In
Japan,
we have been making things with machines for more than 1000 years
. Before and after, it is very difficult to use cutlets, so instead of using another one, we
use wood and wood.  I made it as much as possible by combining it.
Repeating that kind of thing is something that
enthusiasts go to.
[Music]
I'm Takahiro Matsumoto,
a colleague of a palace carpenter.
[Music]
Japanese wooden buildings are
made with care, so
please
combine them with joints. We craftsmen make 4 units, and we combine them.  It ’s about building a building.
After 150 to 200 years
, the building itself
will be damaged. It may rot, it may break, and you may encounter a disaster.
I think I made it with the assumption that Japan will come
.
Yeah
, when I was born, I graduated from junior high school and went to the carpenter's master in the area to become a carpenter.
A world completely different from their own technology created by people in the area called Miya carpenter, starting from the question of how the weak amount of people was made.
There are times when it is necessary to know that there is an
advanced technology, but there is
a building that our predecessors left behind, so
we are learning now as
well.  I know what Japanese people want to do with what they inherited from their ancestors.
[Music] In
total,
I go to shrines and go to shrines at any time,
so I am protected by God and Buddha.  I'm proud of the spiritual support of serving customers with that feeling and that
kind of god. That's what I
really like. What our ancestors
have to do, even if they're old, have to take good care of them.
What are we trying to convey to us?
We will learn from that.
[Music]